we're sorry so a Philippe it real quick
where can they find your podcast on a
weekly basis I'm going to warm iTunes or
SoundCloud Spotify Pandora now Google
all platforms all platforms their en you
can go to Felipe's Worldcom slash
podcast yeah we have like 250 episodes
yeah 251 yeah the first three episode
man we were starting off so I put your
bottom real high if you janitors forget
about it we were doing it always starts
a little bit like that you know already
it's like you don't start in a mansion
we're live what's a podcast were so boom
we got with real tourists today March a
reso straight from doing our Jimmy
Neutron live on Broadway he says sparse
right here all the way from walking to
dogs is by ourselves last weekend and we
have a special get rug see what
world-famous Roxie man 30 million
airboat Roxy Bradley used to have a
billboard bro writer put up my house bro
when when you were on that Shore God we
have billboards for that show yeah when
you think it it produced by genuine rose
what channel is that on it was on moon
balls which is now our moon those yeah
why do you change it at that station was
like legend windows to know like every
time they want to started like they have
moon door to the moon right which is
pretty much our mom my dad you always
try to be yeah we're totally for the
your kids yeah moon dogs but they don't
forget to throw money more money
yeah
it was like for the bilingual millennial
you feel mr. kids like Jeff bought this
or micro bleep put their comedy show
mundos or well that was microbus you
know what it is I think they need people
like us that actually understand the
millennial generation because then you
got like these white dudes or these
white you know like these people that
don't and nothing against white people
we love white black Asian everything but
they get these people that don't really
understand the lifestyle in the
day-to-day and then it fails yeah like
they want to go do them you know dude
bless the white guy he wants to help but
um yeah yes great intentions I don't
want direct you know Maury uh hit so
here putting it like putting like a
bunch of stylus out on a table or put it
like somebody's [__] playing guitar
and figure out that's and we're only
having dinner dog we don't have a big
party just for dinner bro every night
huh it makes sense you know you saw that
video that um that do your Hughley or
somebody post about Denzel Washington
and they were asking him about um about
why did you want a black a director to
direct that movie who was then right he
goes well because I think he would have
done it better he goes what do you mean
must be Steven Spielberg you know he
drew out the children's list and some
other guys directed some other more Oh
Martin Scorsese directed Goodfellas hmm
you know he was critically directed
Schindler's List you know a probably
Spielberg could direct um could do right
for Goodfellas but see a white director
and you don't know about ah a hot comb
you know the smell of a hardcore yeah
the feeling you get you know yeah so
that's what you need someone you know
someone that's a part of that who
basically you say steel brilliant I know
[__] about a hot comb you know yeah and
you can imagine what it is or chase you
don't know [__] about that but I don't
understand you know like did you say we
have a white guy direct something here
like a bunch of like startup is on the
table
no on the couches bro yeah
we have to Salafis on our cow so like
the Virgin Mary she always has Christmas
lights in every movie yeah no you're not
growing up like we always around the
house and have like images of like has
to crystal and it was like dramatic
images like I remember my mom had this
oh my it was my mom like it's always a
mom you know God where's our mothers but
like it was like a portrait of his don't
know where they got the blood you know I
hate my feet man if I could I would take
a shower of my exam bro
water shoes on because there's no bad
feet like they're bad or whether you
know I just never liked feet dude do my
dogs you would hate having a girlfriend
like me I like my toes sucked didn't you
get your did it hit our goal but
thousand subscribers that's what's
supposed to do suck on my toes but we
didn't reach our going let's we'll do
anything man I say we shake that he does
that what other signs tattoos straight
teen type of guy right at first at the
beginning yeah he just he just was he
was big boys stunt guy and he just
started doing wild stuff and that's how
he got offered his Reuters radio job
isn't that crazy
you started Chicago right I actually
started radio my first gig in Palm
Springs
yeah which I heard what comedian started
out there wasn't it like one of the
late-night guys
oh it was probably isn't a Jimmy Kimmel
or no the guy with the red hair the guy
with the red hair
it's a guy from the he's the producer of
the other voice Oh Carson Daly awesome
yeah I probably look Jimmy Kimmel's
Vegas Vegas I don't know I don't know
one of the comedian's started out there
but yeah I started at the hip-hop
station out there my first gig was a
morning show co-host morning every
morning hey guys my fruit but but you
got to remember Palm Springs is marking
number like 122 like nobody cares about
Fox you know what I mean people it's
only old people that live in Mickey hi
everybody on YouTube it's only people
that um that old people go to Palm
Springs because of the heat it's good
for their bones you know yeah a lot of
clinics yeah it's really go like the
mineral water spas and all that stuff
and so I didn't know what the heck I was
doing I was like the only reason I got
that job was because I was recommended
by somebody where I was in half and it
was so freakin high 25 degrees out there
oh my god I was there a year and a half
and then like I felt I felt like I was
my energy was like too big for the city
and I was a part-time cashier at smart
final smarter yeah and then I was and I
was full-time on the radio because you
know market 1:22 you're not making money
you like seriously you're in a garage
you're literally you're in a studio and
but but you know what everybody was like
that
your homecoming Roxy I like you versus
that you have one of those studios were
all wood and you smother last two guys
over there like when I first started
yeah like you smell like the last dude
that was there you know was actually a
pretty nice studio with a legit radio
but then again it's possibly I shouldn't
compare to yeah come over but you've
done stuff in some cities I'm surprised
remember I'd like the majors I did it
one time where that guy opened up
littles in you know I gotta go in
[__] rad bro I ran back to this you
know if they were the producer right but
now man it was a DJ study so no we're
back and we're looking for a long time
now for a long time Wow he came out and
the reception comes in at 9:00 he comes
in at 6:00
did the show with in the basement studio
yeah it's good you know the radio thing
I think it anytime you start developing
your career at a young age like the
struggle is the the grain I'm not even
what yeah it's kind of a struggle
sometimes too but the grind is real when
you kind of have a focus for yourself
and you you know you kind of don't know
the way you're just learning as you guys
know people don't understand a struggle
like you understand you Roxy how could
it be you in one minute you gonna think
I'm any [__] yeah they want to
be you a you're at right now is struggle
because they see that all they see now I
just tagged along with you there now
gets a little Fame to be what you get
different fans what okay Yuri Roxy do
you build yourself to what you are now
well imagine I started in radio in 2000
as an intern it's like weren't 2019 like
I've been writing for 19 years
you know I'm gonna put it's a long I
know I know I've never aged it's all
about the collagen and Botox you're in
an industry though where you could also
it's uncertain swagatam
bought out stations are bought out then
they like oh we have too many morning
crew people now and
yeah and I do we're merging got to
morning gotta get rid of the morning
jungle get rid of somebody on the
afternoon
you know what I've gone through that I
remember when I was working at a station
in LA they decided to make this Power
Move according to them and bring in a
radio personality from Miami that was
gonna cover the Miami market and the LA
market and I'm like oh my gosh okay you
know and there was all of us that had no
more room for Roxy so like I thought
like what Tom Joyner did basically but
they would stay in one place
yeah and if he flew back yeah yeah and
so I've gone through those ups and downs
in my career you know but I think the
overall lesson that I've learned in
being a radio personality and just being
Who I am and really embracing Who I am
is you got to really develop you and and
really understand your value that you
bring to a company you know what I mean
because like nobody else is Philippe
Esparza nobody else is Roxy and not
saying that nobody you know that we're
like Almighty at all but just when you
start to realize the power of your
uniqueness and what you bring to the
table you know you develop a brand and
and yeah you just
but the grind is real on a daily basis
you know and I like it I wouldn't have
it any other way so after a pause
because that cuz I like I get people to
hit me up and go Philippe I couldn't be
a comedian bro first of all man think
about what you're asking you you wanna
be you want to know the hard way or the
easy way you know the easy way
well there you know easy way there is no
easy way they think that they're gonna
get where we're at overnight you know
it's sad you win a contest on the door
there and it's gonna take a long time
bro
because you know you're not that cute
first of all because all your brethren
like like with you it's it's like you
know like where did you start performing
I started off at the natural fudge on
fountain Avenue and Los Feliz though the
open mic there are Monday nights and I
and I went to I saw highly weekly and I
look for comedy but I have no idea about
that some people actually read
newspapers still yeah yeah
Allawi Cleo's my agent that and the back
backstage
yeah drama-logue fever
but then later on you will find like
comedy shows like in the back of pages
and I would just so I know when I was in
apply there and I'm and now telling her
I don't have a lot of jokes so I draw I
wrote this joke I said I'm they made a
movie called The Last of the Mohicans
I'm coming in a new movie called
laughter the mahalos about a guy who
didn't know he did legal you know
whatever remember that my first joke
yeah I love that and you but you know
what I could guarantee though that you
didn't start you didn't start getting
into comedy with the mentality of like I
wanna be famous literally like me when I
started in radio when I started
interning I literally loved the art of
being able to communicate and express
myself through a microphone you know it
wasn't like I want to do this because I
want to be famous and I feel like we
live in a time now where everybody wants
to be famous and we didn't have when I
started like we didn't have my oh we
Adam I do I know my space party like my
ex-boyfriend my second boyfriend threw
mice because I put out a bulletin that I
was looking for a dope tattoo artists
and they ended up recommending me to his
Spa and crazy like I would put bulletins
on MySpace you remember those days you
would the Dodger Stadium wait who I
remember man like I used to look like a
thug like well he was like a thug I mean
I kind of liked that boy well get the
two was it what kind of tattoo was it
what that he did I what do you got yeah
oh he bent at me he was just the owner
of it like one of his best artists had
it well they're really good though yeah
you gotta go to a tutu on her shoulder
octopus octopus what is an octopus mean
to you it doesn't mean anything
that's my Rico life that's really nice
Marty school life I'm all about a beach
a lot is beautiful I like it
wow I want to get I did you know she
loved a little bit oh wow that looks
like an exotic free eat mermaid
seriously Aquaman is like that's why I
marry this girl
you're a durian i'm Salvadorian sierra
we're like we're so different and I know
my you Gugu why do Mexican a fortune
shows up is hey Salvador's why my last
three boyfriend's were Mexican yeah I
don't hate me why do some adore is and
it's a white hate Mexican yeah I guess
people like looking up so much right
yeah
man people believe those mushy
stereotypes I'm like don't believe it my
brother married a solid or a girl is he
a happy man he's super happy
oh hell yeah and what they're both
righteous I went there to up we were to
meet Lisa we went to the raft
Thanksgiving you know she invited us you
get there my monocle Wow [__] okay
we were so mad they had that wow we
respected turkey gravy mashed potatoes
ham [__] pie you know something
that's gonna take a long time and we're
gonna bake pies I don't know if she made
any but let me tell you she made that
thing out of a sorry cream and I was and
sweetener wet at the fruit deeper way
and fruit there you go deep oh I can
make a it's literally like it's cream
fruit juice cream cheese with please no
that's a no the monkey is awfully big
and that Lisa broke her knee on
Thanksgiving
yeah hold on I got a googly eye but I've
made one of my mom's clay monitors makes
the bomb is fruit dip but let me tell
you something about the Salvadorian
turkey there is like I don't know if it
was cooked properly
the way was all good right oh my gosh a
Salvadoran turkey takes like oh good
good one that's made with like the 10
million spices that we make it with will
literally take like four to five hours
to make it is the juiciest it is turkey
that you will ever taste a new Daniel at
that you follow they are there turkeys
in salvador are there turkey you got
there I'm sure there isn't there oh oh
oh they're next door
I'm sorry guavas not iguanas they sell
the dish iguana
yes called water like my mom would love
this why don't like he knows how to eat
that - everything boney Tai Chi Keith up
in the heat that I don't see you said
you want me to I thought I said they're
doing comedy in Spanish let you eat up
yeah you have seemed like a combatant
also will save me I have you're asking
for a favor
playing sweet Thomas I see that no way
nice way of saying like instead of Gora
Gora Lita Mira's gorilla like I guess
like you know we'll call you father many
me oh I have a deer that's like that I'm
speaking your arms is what you do it's
just like she's like she's don't crying
when she says it - it's my grandmother
it's my grandma's
sister so she's like my Tia Ella you
know and she'll say um she'll say she'll
say it's like - three pounds and she's
like maybe many but I got all nice and
I'm like but see Thea and she's like
that me that must go to that and she
don't even say go to her
let's get jet-assisted meet I mean
plateaus and I'm just like damn do like
no [__] but I also I also appreciate
people like that that are are quick to
tell you like a dude like you've packed
on a couple of pounds like oh yeah
you're right you know I'm saying I have
been eating a lot I kind of appreciate
honest people like that you know unless
you lean the other after-sales - yeah
let you letting me and the gym believe
what's your favorite thing to do after
sex eat man oh god I love preferable ice
cream Gary's body man dairymaid down we
do have to say another you are gonna
kill you give her CPR what's the dog
like good dies yeah the little dog's
watching yeah uh how the dog walked in
while you're having sex
that looks your bajo people never reach
my god we have to now
you have two pits now we rescued a guy
named Henry Chinaski Jupitus yeah yeah
the other ones a mix with something I
don't know but he looks less oh I'd love
I is the one that rides with you in your
car on Instagram is that a boy or girl
girl she's so huge
what's her name squishy squish I almost
brought her but she was sleeping oh
where we got her she would like 55
pounds or 45 55 pounds oh my god well
you know I had under it's right yeah
whatever that's the way look I got his
paw print on look oh my
I got servos paw print on my head turbo
and then chill I still have her she's
four years old she's my little consent
either
did she miss him uh you know I we both
miss him terribly I go through those
days of like is you know turbo was my
companion for he was 14 years old and
eight months Wow but let me tell you the
whole time I had the whole time oh my
god you don't even know and but let me
tell you how I helped him live a long
life and I'm a big advocate CBD CBD
would add 11 years old
turbo started slowing down and I was
like oh hell no I can't lose them this
is my boy like I love him right and I
was like I'm gonna get him a female let
me get him a female and to see if that
you know gets him excited so he came
back to life for like three years then I
started seeing him slow down again I was
like CBD CBD and it extended his life 14
years old eight months he was almost 15
yeah and he died in my arms at my house
with me and like I knew I kind of knew
something told me like that was his last
day it was the craziest thing Wow
it was like a crazy connection you have
with the dog you know cuz you know them
and they know you I'm like down they've
Sorokin talked whoa
we've been through a lot he's seen a lot
my girlfriends dogs they only want to
talk or like little people is what
happened here right here female dog to
your arm to your male dog I don't take
it to get him to like each other you
know what um man they liked each other
instantly you know cuz I try to bring
another the male dog out cuz when I
started thinking about another dog I
brought I was like let me just test
different dogs so I brought this one
baby a baby he was like a month or two
months pitbull around turbo and he was
turbo with on the corner when he was
still alive and then when I brought the
but the little boy the little puppy he
was like he started growling so to me
that was a sign he don't like her he he
don't like this dog once I brought Shula
OH
they were all over each other instantly
I was like this is hurt this is hurt and
I
as long as the dog doesn't growl like
you gotta respect the G the one that's
been there with you the longest you know
what I mean he's the he's the one
and so when turbo passed man my house
felt so empty because when you got a pit
and turbo was like solid 120 he was big
120 he was a beast yeah he was from a
blood line called Butthead so they have
big heads like humans like weed strains
are like yes seriously
and so when he passed away oh man I felt
this emptiness in my home it was crate
like I felt my security was gone because
when you got a pig no one's coming into
your house can i and I had them trained
like be nice but when you need to attack
you need to attack like certain keywords
they'll never share your attack words
with people if anything you know you
never know is a pit life span usually
about 15 years you know what one of my
boys that works for the animal animal
control he up its lifespan is around 12
years really yeah so he was like man
Roxy you were a great dog owner like
trying to console my heart you know what
are you still god oh yeah old management
it seems they can be a dog Henry
Chinaski
well now we we saw him on some on some
dog shelter page right and he came in
there like the owner put him up put him
at item out to the gate left him there
bleeding from blood squirting out at him
and someone left a message
you never take this dog they're gonna
put up some sleep so some some
volunteers at the shelter yeah Josh
critters right Josh and his critters
Josh's critters just the network like a
rescue now yeah they picked up Henry and
they took him to their house and we
donate donate money but we donate money
for medical and I think in three months
he got better
I think it's been two months he's just
an old ratty dog he's 11 years old ten
years old but our other ones too
it's getting some growing or some stuff
in it around
Pino there's a growth or growth but it
was like a macro bleeding everywhere
right but now is he's alright bony Peas
he's pretty sideways II there's no
control over where it goes he's so happy
Oh control like when he goes outside
he's super happy it's like who could do
that to a dime I asked like it was a
heart to do that and he had like his jaw
his lip has like loose like it was torn
from his ears all beat up co2 guess he
was like a bait dog lately trainer he
probably he could have been yeah well he
must that dog must have done something
good in their past life because they got
you guys I feel like when somebody
rescue the dog you guys you've basically
changed our dog's life exactly she was
our first thought she was bad bleeding
like well she just had raw spots that
she was bleeding on you know not from
her ass put our TV at the house a heroin
addiction that's awesome guys got them
you know like they're like they're gonna
be with you for like their last good
yeah you guys oh my gosh in the twilight
of that love you guys now even more dogs
they might not live a long time but they
live a good life Henry London from
England hello there hello Lulu hello
Jesse hello ATL you oh it's amazingly
they Youth need to hear our story I
agree it Felipe we should start like we
should go talk to high schools man and
like right we should let's we just got
that idea thank you just picture the
principal they were good but I'm back
now
let me tell you people that are on
antidepressants medicated legal
antidepressants are more likely to
commit suicide and I'm just like
antidepressants are supposed to help you
not make you feel more down and
depressed man like you know we can have
a whole entire conversation about
Academies you know and it's a healing
herb it's just been misconstrued we put
our CBD oil in our dog's food now motion
oh I have a good lotion I'm gonna send
you a screenshot later no it's like a
hemp like the one that's melt yes
no it's melt melt melt melt does that
been around me yeah the Queen makes it I
think oh I like cush it has a little bit
of but it smells good and it's immediate
it's a yeah no but to answer your
question Philippe I grew up in Riverside
Ruben LBC no I live long beach notice
the high school yeah for Willow Avenue
in Long Beach now no no I back Motor
City my first boyfriend yeah he took
math along which is a nice black
Riverside Rubidoux high school Ruby yeah
yeah I lived in Riverside win I know
there are a lot of unsolved murders in
Rubidoux yeah I like Rubidoux was not
Hugh it was like a really small town in
Riverside West Side PJ's website like it
was you know it was it was I mean it was
middle class I would say yeah I was
middle lower middle class lower middle
class like I was the kind of young girl
Philippe at a young age that I started
hustling young I had a lemonade stand
and I wouldn't run the metro or what I
had a little we lived in a cold a sack
and I would set up my table and I'd be
like lemonade lemonade 25 cents and my
dad would be like dude I let me ha
I always have those parents that would
encourage me that like if I wanted to be
creative they would like go sell it then
like you know and I was like okay and
and I literally you know we grew up on
kool-aid kool-aid and white refined
sugar like that was the [__]
and it was like little pocket Ito's at
kool-aid like that Oh long way bro
strawberry but art the funk was like
lemonade we love live everything had
lemon in every meal we drank lemonade my
dad was the kind of dad that he would we
would have our lemonade they're like
just you know when you're a kid you just
want to drink everything and he would
make us eat our food before we would
drink our beverage so now like as an
adult when I'm eating I can't drink
liquids because I have to finish my food
then I chug it down you never saying but
it's so crazy like my parents just let
us fly like birds you be a brother drink
your lemonade yeah yeah brothers I have
a brother and a sister I'm the baby
your sisters the one that the beauty
salon yeah my sister she's my
hairstylist also she did that no no I
have a home girl from for her name is
Josie from Inglewood from the hood
charge you Joe Sena [__] yes yes but a
lot of people when they see my hair
they're like oh who rated you an
african-american girl like know a lot
Deena my wife raised my hair she's
degrade black girls hair too
oh so you're a breeder like listen I
grew up with black girls and I would say
black school and we're neighborhood oh
hi thank you no hi oh we're a little
gangsta queer Roger and zappers brother
see Roger walk around a fur coat in the
middle of nowhere
nowadays the fur coat anywhere in the
hood in the summer no but he if a he own
Chopin studios though that was nearby he
was like king of the neighborhood oh
yeah I didn't live in his name Lisa
likes boxes you see that I'm catching on
to your blows over
yeah so that that's where I grew up but
yeah I braided hair and I used to make
money that way in college a little bit
that braids or strips no I did
hey cardi B use to be a stripper and it
wasn't a bad always been so like have a
boyfriend right my boyfriend I want to
like I'm like no no no I have a
boyfriend that's like my man right like
I'm only with him and like we have like
this big like king-size bed this is Mike
my fantasy and like just one night when
we're about to like get freaky he's just
like he's like baby just dance for me
and I dance for him and he just like
throws hundreds at me and just and then
but he have to let me keep him so I go
shopping after oh I'm like baby I'm here
invest in me that night as I'm gonna let
you invest in me he said would you take
coupons will be a big California king
right yeah that what you have wrong no
ladies probably that big - will we have
sex that'd be the sky Zone in two
separate beds like Ricky and Lucy
remember we push the beds together when
we get freaky what Betty you have
believed in here Californication outlook
we have a regular King regular King
California King and a greater it's like
four inches longer
he is whiter California king is white
now later
oh yeah are you no no
you're right it's it's wider it's four
inches wider I think the standard king
of the ones in the hotels I don't know I
just knew because mine I always had the
middle I would had a queen bro or the
four sides and what time we had a twin
right no we didn't know what we had a
twin in the camper when we did Aaron
[__] we were playing that game we put
your what's that game where you put
there's two oh my god where I was I was
trying wedged up between the bed and the
window like just on the side I say I'll
just stay over here so after you left
Palm Springs when did you let in our
lane so after I left okay so my route my
my radial journey continues I started
upon seeing them after that I went to
Chicago I went to do I went to Chicago
to do Mexican cartel shy town for sure
I wonder shy how is checking in checking
search I said I'll be there this weekend
it's a big oh yeah this Saturday you
know Chicago was one of my favorite
cities it is a blood oh I didn't know
there was so many Mexicans to one guide
I opened up a book and there was like
these Aztec warrior dancers huh maybe
where is this sad you know energy cog oh
yeah Jolson yes the south side of
Chicago is like it's like going to
Huntington Park it's it's really super
Latinos yeah a lot of Mykonos now you're
getting something you up in the book I
opened up my yellow pages nothing but
Mexican names so I went to Chicago and I
worked in Mexican regional radio at a
station call a ciento siete Punto no a
la la and you know like I'm starting I
grew up listening to like Celia Cruz
cumbia with Miguel not really Vonda and
and you know I knew who I know Vicente
Fernandez because she's a classic
artist but so vonda to me was was so
Lisa yeah like you I remember we
interviewed a como se llama
the biggest van de como se llama death
on goose Lizarraga van de colo
and I didn't know who these guys were so
like if I see who Ellen and Pancho like
the main guys they know who I like we go
way back you know and I'd like los loros
Kapalua dango I met all a Mexican
regional accents where I met the Rivera
family Juan and wheel she would know
better family in Chicago in Chicago I
met one who I was like my first friend
you know of the whole family and then
and then from there I came to LA in 2005
it was the same company I just like they
didn't want to transfer me so I quit my
gig in Chicago and I quit with the fate
that they were gonna rehire me and I was
persistent and they did and I ended up
on you know Latino now it's a different
station name but you know sweet by
lingual 96.3 yeah oh yeah and so I I
like to credit myself but that's one
like the whole Spanglish yeah in 2005
yeah so 2005 is is I was one of those
pioneers in radio in LA because I
remember LA like stations like power 106
other stations were like what is this
new station because we were playing but
I get thorn and hip hop and then we had
a concert one time that was like Snoop
Dogg and daddy yankee and it was
literally like really bringing the
station's together now the station
speaks more Spanish I've noticed but it
was I'd love to know that I was part of
that whole movement like when Evie
Queens started popping out here yeah you
know when the bling down nails like
everyone thinks cardis like the
originator going down I'm like I was
getting my nails blinged out years ago
at a backyard in Compton you know with
chi-chi's and I will go get our nails
done there so it was it yeah and then
Here I am 2019 back in the day we were
like shrimp bro other signs Burroughs
borsky crystals I would rock off that
did you rock those big-ass dolphin puka
shells - you mean the dolphin hoops
dolphin hoops no bamboo hoops yeah but
not dolphin what are not mean who am I
not in my neighborhood
they have the regular hoops yeah we have
look girlie to wear like it was just
like two big-ass dolphins going around
each other you see them right infinity
dolphin how'd you learn that reality
show you know what how did we learn the
reality show at that time I was I was
friend yeah I had an interview Jenny a
few times on the station and then I had
started creating a relationship or her
manager at that time and yeah and and we
started talking about just like the
concept first the concept was a reality
show about like a group of girls it
wasn't really just about me and Jenny's
daughter it was just about and then we
just kind of like started auditioning
different girls cuz we were both gonna
executive producer together and we
really didn't find women or girls that
kind of moved us that had a personality
we were just like uh then what he's just
like you know what I think you and she
used to make a good combination and then
Jenny got behind it and Jenny was hot
already and super on her rise and yeah
we created the first reality show on it
was the first day I'd never tapped into
the reality show side of television on
moonless earth Telemundo and then when
they saw the numbers that that reality
show did now they have like Larry
Hernandez has a reality show
bigger yeah I think and that's I had a
reality show on there and you know the
Rivera's have the reality show on there
so it was like I love to know that you
know I was part of that movement so yeah
that's that's how that happened but
reality TV is really interesting would
you do a reality show about your whole
life would they follow you what now you
know what I think I would but I would
definitely want to be more in creative
control of like my mom my sister and me
oh yeah I you know I want my content
you'll your own it yeah yeah I
definitely learn as you go through
different experiences because my mom my
sister and I I call were like the Holy
Trinity us three together so if my mom's
from a different generation my sisters
from has a different life than me and
but we're all tight little mom come to
America my mom was born here Oh Warren
Empire a general hospital that lives
she came in though her parents my
parents were hurt my grandparents my
grandparents are born in Assam all the
way so they came into 80s in early 80 79
or the mega evolution yeah no I think
they were here before I think they came
after the war I I'm not actually I think
it's I need to research that a little
bit more I was in the early eighties
that war right yeah my dad so my mom
goes out my grandma sends my Mike mom
and my diya
out too and some allured like their
junior senior year of high school
imagine like culture shock right and so
she sends him out there she meets my dad
he glamour Alcala he para my dad to play
the guitar Utah and they have sex one
time and my mom gets pregnant with my
sister Playa playa I was like that my
daddy was not shooting blanks
Grayson buzz and yeah he gets pregnant
my mom gets pregnant and then my dad
comes over here so my you know my family
I don't have that that immigrant story
of like they had across the river thank
God because my dad got my mom pregnant
so Segundo con una green eye and he got
papers you know ever so he was here at
21 yeah that's what you do you better
find me a little youngster out some
papers I like you're honest about that
you know that's not really an immigrant
story cuz a lot of people coming out
with their own yeah but you're born here
I'm here
come on came here know what she came
here in the 70s after my grandpa died am
i I'm I told you uh when my grandpa died
my grandma hooked up with her brother
with his
and they had another baby so yeah people
over here after that one go yeah but uh
he moved out here he was real carpenter
out here for a while and they met in a
wood huh yeah maybe hola follow me mama
splinters to Paolo symbol oh he said
Bello Bello so what are you doing now I
know you I know you did your podcast the
one or the other one with Ruby yeah
so now I'm gonna be a cholo yeah ya know
who is that oh ho ho me she has a dude
that like oh it works as like a producer
or psychic the strain of hard core cholo
ah but there's like one bro you know if
he walks bro they're gonna hit him up
yeah well anyway so because of the home
ohohohohoh me we follow this guy named
Latin Tony sure to let the Tony where
the most of them right he's a rapper
oh the guy that just came out of the
closet nobody no one else who's here
deadly super super cold a cholo
rapper yeah you bang homie yeah so what
it was that that meme is like some buff
dude he gave me and then it says when
your safe word is there but he's saying
there hold on I don't know why this
isn't working I need to close all my
tabs oh my god have you ever it like I
haven't way too many to have open on my
phone
seriously oh my god are you reading the
comments yeah too much to read too much
to read
I mean how much dumb and you're tapped
when you when you had the radio job how
much dumb this is mrs. NAT Sookie is a
video what's up boo what's our full
podcast yes
tune in yeah yes so like you just can't
be a radio disc jockey no more now you
told you got to be on social media
you're gonna put on makeup in the
morning irons well I do but I don't do
tutorials about it because there's
there's people out there that I think
they're really makeup artists but
they're really not they just got really
good at doing their makeup from so much
practice and and you know what I mean
they're but they're they're considered
makeup gurus and the Kylie cosmetics of
the world and different people have done
packaging millions of followers yeah
people love watching makeup tutorial
what's your favorite thing to watch on
YouTube food I'm vegan and I don't even
need the food or make you but about five
fights to go a little fights Melanie
might you want to fight with a black
people oh did you know that the whole
case got taken to the DA now big boy -
yeah video yeah oh my gosh I tried to go
together as one so there was like it's
like one baby mama is here with a new
man and then that the guy is there with
his lady and they know they were gonna
know they went together to hear this
story
we saw it putting some I watch it yeah
in the video
we don't know each other yeah walking
with his baby this new lady and he chose
run to his old lady goes a met don't
even split my baby like that I think I
was a red shirt they start arguing right
after arguing let you guys know her him
and the lady oh so then her masters like
maybe a kid away from me so then they
start arguing him and that guy but then
his lady starts talking [__] to that guy
so he punches her and
so then he punches his lady
yeah his baby mama don't even punch each
other yeah somebody said it was getaway
pretend this was a pie fight and all the
women guy he was pies yeah oh my but the
guy with the red shirt that was the
Fenians girlfriend later beat up his
going somebody told him that she tripped
his mama
the people fighting among each other
they knew each other
the by dysfunctional family man oh my
gosh we're about to Google this fight at
Disneyland hello we need to tone is
battle road to China's ghetto bro wait
are we gonna watch this okay we're gonna
watch this live it no I throw ball
breeze like the news did it show the
entire video they just show like a piece
okay here we go oh my god baby my shirt
and the mom falls by accident
what you doing off your bike I finally
help brown and you didn't see all that
the guy in red the guy's girl in black
she's your mama [__] so he's beating
her up now I can't who the guy in the
red that's the main guy out on the floor
a woman like nothing tells him yeah well
you
baby mama now yeah a month to imagine he
does is like how he doesn't a public
yeah [__] that dude like meaning like
they don't get along know they're
together just like he's turned on her
because it's a painful relationship my
got a man that lives his hand up if you
listen to the video he says I'm gonna
jail tonight and he's uh I'm a
neighborhood yeah he's going to jail
some who I need he says he's a crow bees
were in a red shirt he's a guy trying to
read his hand at me oh hell no well I
mean I wish to do it oh no I don't wish
I was too sick did I get brutal Oh
during sex you get brutal that's ok
during sex touch me [__] don't ever
make me a sandwich oh my gosh no that
was bad that was ooh that video was
disturbing it's hard to what are you uh
how do you make peace after that you
can't do that like 19 crimes right there
you can't make peace and as that woman
is that really how you want people to
see your relationship across the world
they're gonna be on the whole the whole
everybody in that fight gonna be on
Wendy next week control your emotions
you're out of control in life like if
somebody's gonna piss you off so easily
sure and call you a name and you beard
yours if you're that reactive in life
like you need to go within and be like
okay why is everything make me react why
am I so angry it's not about your baby
mama it's not about nobody with you
that's never being in take
accountability for you like don't get me
started
you don't think about stuff like you do
by anything you know
got that Disneyland act that [__]
McDonald's
Oh big not horrible or behind closed
doors everybody good night you play trip
the microphone at the cashier to hell
with it I'm sorry that it took forever
for the security to get there you would
think as it's Disneyland they'd be there
nobody where Mickey ears is ready to
fight you're going to Disneyland you're
gonna roll it by pushing it we're gonna
talk to you because they're black what
is she news where the [__]
stormtroopers is the Jedi book is third
super surgeon was the Rangers fight in a
lot of food now you know your mama your
Hideo [__] you're right yeah she loves
you oh yeah she does love me yeah well
it'll be funny brother super hey that's
a good comedy bit right there yeah do
you just come up with those like
honorable I you do huh you have a really
creative minds I try it man are you that
creative and when you have sex yeah my
other dog doesn't know he does well he
will lick anything you know too much Oh
what tools I don't like balls that's
because you sound boring what I had a
baby wipe and wipe
and then you go into a little bit of
flavor get a bunch of clubbers on your
hands we love her basketball watching
down why'd you go there oh my Thomas
Esparza Tommy oh my god Edison Esparza
funny man I had this joke I was because
I met these people right they don't like
swingers right yeah and then when I went
back I could never bring my wife to go
swing somewhere because I'll just be too
excited to be there somebody put my
balls I'd come real fast and really my
wife [__] everybody whole night oh my
god that's why could it man I'll be too
excited I somebody played my boss a
stranger yeah they're so loud that might
come too fast brother
it'll be over I'm gonna watch my wife
[__] everybody horrible we're a mask I
know I think most of the women are
trying to just avoid being chosen at
those events they have to I've never
gone to a senior event no no like how do
you get invited to that stuff there by
Devore in a Sammartino orissa wait you
think I'm ho oh you you can pay if
you're a guy you pay 40 bucks but you
have to bring a girl with you if you
don't you pay under seed okay that's the
[__] tax bro how do you know so you hold
me there flips cards oh man I walked in
D o bomb a splash it's crazy man but the
only wasn't wanted to [__] me with fat
[__] in PA you do that whatever
that's my homie Jeff get deep in New
York for Rubidoux the River Seine
my homie robbed some Rubidoux - they
also have cars in Phoenix we have a lot
of places later part - Wow whatever I
was caught in counters I think I can run
out of them he said in college so what
do you do you go there with your with
your swingy partner and then you just
like is it like a buffet like yeah yeah
it's open that they want it with you you
walking around you can't go jumping yeah
never buffet and have food there said
they have Locker it's like a partner's
experience
we're not passionate with Paul Rodriguez
one time and there was a burrito a
burrito lady came in at 2:00 in the
morning with them aluminum foil really
well breakfast burritos our boss's girl
hit me orientated and she was just chica
blows to me with big boobs would you
like a private dancer I saved my money
for the Berean apology is a Madeira
glacial ocean I'm stay away from people
who talk to me bro like for the cashier
the bar like he's counting on his money
in his pocket knowing how much he's got
that will blow by - burrito bro you want
to die in one an airplane that's over
self I want two of them yeah that girl
just looked at me lips I'm gonna go tell
my friend she was rejected for a burrito
I'm gonna go tell her friend and they
all laugh and then one don't flip me off
oh my gosh you could have had a burrito
dude or such a mouth remember oh hi with
Ivan and I we were just really only ones
there was no cash it was you know
private dance now
good well why not I'm saving it for a
burrito Mexican lady gonna be here
another hot chick right he walked away
Sharif I know she broke my shoulders
they are good huh every time a nothing
but like you know Passover the only
people you see like strippers and
they're in the [__] heels in her
wedges eating a burrito bro no soda take
a little break a cigarette and forty in
the side in one of those prostitution
movies we watching we were watching the
documentary of them in Mexico remember
and then the like paisa ladies is just
waiting outside the hotel rooms and they
just look all beaten but they're like
stay at the motel documentaries where I
could see like what I can't remember
what that one was called was it part of
that series that the Japanese ones yes
no it's which one oh my god I've gone to
other Leto's that for all that you see
those the ones are on the street all
kind of look like a little stray dogs no
I guess not
how much are they like an x-ray I mean
are they pre the fools they don't want
to spend money at Italy he'll get those
ones oh those are the ones you do great
voices man well you know somebody horse
Gloria I think [__] Gloria theory
Laurie there's one in Bangladesh that
they focus on all the wouldn't better -
kids living in that broth
[__] is glory [__] glory like a horse
or war is glory horse like apostrophe s
[__] wh or possibly Oh Lord glory
[__] worry there's one that's it
Mexico right but there's that bang that
that's one is so that the one the
whorehouse in Bangladesh is so sad like
in a little mall and they all live in
blankets and there's like young girl
like 13 years old and they pretty much
like her mom with a [__] her grab her
life her grand
great-grandmother with a [__] through
the grand [__] you know I got a Buddha
in Essaouira though it is not offensive
it's it's it's kind of like okay you say
puta like a mini but I gotta put on a
whole ass like it's just very much part
of my well I got a Buddha like like
that's kind of like like it could be
like II what puta
it's all about the inflection and the
lights like forget about a [__] it's
two different it's all about the tone so
I can say it to my grandma oh yeah yeah
but it's very it's very like saying way
it's very common in us on mother
Guatemalans to and then you know like to
us the V word you know like it's it's
it's very common for - in Mexico that's
the man's private part yeah yeah Tasos
that's yeah yeah yeah you know kind of
like move if I may hit you like
so what if you're gay you don't know
what paid I met with where do style
Dorian get all these European names like
I made lots of Dorian's was the name of
Sally like Jennifer like Courtney well
damn I mean spread the Spanish it over
everything
his name's if you go to Mexico City like
and you go visit el castillo de
chapultepec you know cuz I went there
last year for the first time like the
it's it's it's Mexico but like it talks
about all the Spanish conquering they
literally came and took over Mexico so
Mexico Central America is all very much
influenced by the Spanish so like my
last name is Cordova like there's a town
in Spain Kahlua but my grandfather
changed it from a be the Baraboo
Roosevelt vodka so I have a very Spanish
like like I'm gonna bring yeah
right like I have a very Spanish last
theme so that's my theory but is
conquered and my family my friend
neighbor world they all have American
name least that and there were the other
one is Raul but they're written in the
one in there Wendy Wendy and then that
wondering what went ago named Elvis milk
on my first name yeah first me yeah
the first name Ryan yeah it the other
day I was at the beach and I was like
there was just like white family next to
me and it's so crazy to hear I was like
I wonder what these kids names alright
cuz I'm like just observing she's like
come here Hunter come here it was it was
a hunter like it's something but I was
like do these names are so why shame
Lance and Travis yeah dragon hunter and
I was like oh my gosh I always hated
them in Cody Cody Oh Cody was Cody and
AJ were on Simon and Simon right it
wasn't Cody the other guy's name
was in Kobe the down syndrome Corie
Corie or Corky Corky
Cody is Philippe in superstore what up
fool the show was tattoo yeah so right
now we're on - radio every morning on
big three radio it's I skew presents big
free radio so big three yeah I use like
the face of it yeah so big three is a
basketball league it's three on three
basketball and so it's right now the NBA
is off season so this is kind of like
you know it's it's big three it's it's
going until I want to say September and
so tat is the voice of the big three and
so came up with this idea he travels
with the league every weekend he travels
yeah going to Brooklyn this weekend and
it's a good gig bro yeah three moves so
fast you got these old so fast
they're like bum alone but my play but
it's like be tired yeah yeah when I
lived in New York they would take over
they would do the three-on-three thing
down in the Wall Street area cuz I lived
down there but not many people were
there on the we how it's blowing huh
yeah so not many people were there on
the weekends so they had the whole
street blocked off and they did the
whole event right there in the middle of
the street it was cool man yeah and it
does it moves fast and it each game is
over fast you know it brings a lot of
excitement I feel like back to
basketball you know because you get to
see these these basketball players that
are like retired or they got you know
because of an injury and they feel like
I'm gonna you know they're invited to
play a lot of energy and a lot of energy
oh man they go move so fast
I've never been to of the or watch those
videos the old ones
remember they have two and one yeah and
one of it yeah guys were amazing and I'm
pros man yeah they weren't like
professional you know yeah yeah they've
straight-up Street bubble and one brings
the same level I'm sorry
3:03 brings the same level yeah but with
pros bro house before you tear they be
some of those videos I got those like
that game Roxy what a big three game
yeah no I haven't gone to a big three
game yet but I know yeah I've gone to
back to boxing I love tat made me love
boxing when he was working with Golden
Boy he made me love boxing like I would
and and I once I was there I realized a
lot of women
the sport of boxing bat boxing and
basketball for me I love it those are
like my two favorites pulling for a team
Lakers duh losing it what do you think
about the Clippers I mean I we were just
having this debate on the air yesterday
that's ball rivalry in LA yeah it's
making basketball exciting again right
nobody's on me everyone you know so um I
like to support all of LA teams
I love the Lakers oh I love the Lakers
but I think we should this is our city
we got to support it how are we gonna
bash like our one of our own teams about
the epic rivalry I love the Dodgers
Chargers Chargers huh Rams Rams I don't
really like the sparks this I like this
works but to referee a game was like I
wouldn't even go to it a clipper game
even if they gave me a front row seat
hanging out with clipper Daryl right
there I know right everybody knows
blooper Daryl yeah no shows on every day
every morning
oh we do a morning show it's from 7:00
to 10:00 in the morning on - radial so -
is a dope digital platform that has over
80 radio stations and it was created by
DJ Skee the theme that we're a big the
bigger boys yeah the Baker boys on that
network um Kylie Jenner has a station on
that network Snoop as a station be real
from Cypress Hill Elton John little yeah
and it's really dope because it's it's a
lot of talent on a lot of different
radio stations and so we get to rock
every I think there's like about five
morning shows on the whole network and
we're one of them so we have a lot of
fun it's it's we talk about the big
three of course we give you the big
three update cuz the big three radio so
it's myself
tattoo and Joe grande who is a legend
when it comes to sports camp Joe
grunting roaring lost boys are part when
it stays better than yelling Joe crying
yeah he's been in like locker rooms with
Kobe when like the 3p pouring champagne
on him like Joe's a really cool guy man
we're really blessed to have each other
because combined it's like a lot of
years we know
mom rule yeah he knows his force he
would love to be on yeah he's a cool
dude
really cool dude - no that's awesome I
used to do those those meetups you do
with a lot of women
yeah really sit down and meditate so I
have my prophet a lot of the women no
saben man you just close your eyes and
just forget about sheer surprise yeah
yeah so I have a non-profit I founded my
nonprofit eight years ago it's called
amigas from my soul and what we are is
we're an organization that focuses on
empowering women and and just tap into
your own power we create events
conferences workshops where you we just
invite you to realize like you are all
that like you are the [__] and you
really don't need external validation
and so I'm the founder and I've created
just different outlets where women could
show up for themselves every month in
different cities and it's a lot of work
but it's really rewarding when you see
women like building their confidence
opening up businesses becoming
entrepreneurs because they're like them
like all I had to do was release my old
my past baggage and and just grow into
who the [__] I am
you know and because I think a lot of us
as humans we hold on to the past like we
hold on to [__] that happened like 30
years ago
hey why you mad all cuz 20 years ago my
mom's like let it go [__] let it
go I know that's noble that would no
matter where we at thank family member
people we know that we're having a
barbecue they'll just turn again their
mom for no reason bro no reason for [__]
ever thirty years ago you know what and
it could be like yeah like let it go
don't go there no more [__] it's so
different of a block yeah like I I get
women that write to me you know that are
like Roxy how do I get over you know my
mom hooking up with my husband
that's a whole nother level of language
Adrian Palm Springs by those fans you
know yeah like it's kind of like how I
when I when I'm presented with like
special cases like that I'm like dad you
know that that that can help what about
that visit my family to hit you over
that's crazy
[Laughter]
you know what it's hard to meditate it's
challenging I'm afraid but okay some
will pray meditate whatever meditation
is literally like clearing your mind out
of everything and it seems like when you
first start meditating admit it but no
no I think when you try to meditate your
your mind when you're not used to it
because when you try to become quiet if
I'm or noise comes in because you're
focused on man it's challenging to do
the really good a lot of people like
okay so I like a lot of people when you
don't understand something you kind of
misjudge it because you don't understand
like when somebody doesn't understand
cannabis they misjudge it how much does
it cost we meditate
awareness oh my god yeah Kundalini Yoga
that's what it is
what about Hindu he does Reiki crazy man
in black here oh my gosh
Martin got married Mary married a family
yeah at the ice for like less than a
year
shut uh that's what she badass was she a
bad [__] I don't know I'm Salvador very
recently no he's in a long-term
relationship but no crazy like Gabriel
glasses took off like a minister clarity
and maybe them he married to me eyes
have to let us marry them with eyes hell
yeah you took a ROP
oh yeah man flunking married their man
night job it was like getting a sitcom
got cancelled sequel later
yeah hey would you ever want to get a
sitcom man we've been trying for years
well we pitch two years ago we'd pitch
last year and we're gonna do good you
know what might get a thousand nose but
eventually we'll get that yes don't stop
man the hot yoga that's the one Joe
Rogan does right I don't know I guess so
I don't really follow Joe I don't know
do you harness the fighting it's in a
like 109 degree room I think all the
Bikram yoga like the creator of Bikram
yoga that do did he like move out to
like another country because he got he
has got to like doing nasty [__] to
women right people who worked for him I
think that's Groban and he would wear
these like little shorts to do with you
love giving long hugs by the way but
they have hug it is good press the
crotch I knew a guy a hug this guy at
the at the Cannabis place in downtown he
was on to yoga and coming up with CBD
oils and dabs and TAC oils that will hug
you
he goes you get it all the spirits out
he would say yeah he'll hug me abroad be
a long-ass hug bro my grandmother hungry
that long nobody hugs me that long to
pick me up
I mean either man my mom I like you and
we're dating I'm giving you a long hug
oh yeah I go oh I'm just like unless
there's like this amazing chemistry
between me and a stranger and I'm my god
damn well fine you gonna give free
tickets give me a hug
[Applause]
no man I can move in a headlight world
you watch everybody bro you can see
they're too long yeah though my brother
a [__] party man at comedian - hell
no you locked up comedian fresh in the
one waiting his joke at the end in love
with fights an actual punch line my
brothers funny he'll get punch but the
people who are listening it punch but my
brother was like yeah hey you know I
used to sing in the church choir
my brother should you both have like
this and then tickle their [__]
because that's opposes me like I want to
do you right yeah but don't [__]
funny who go to everybody even the
priests oh my god is it a no I love the
fine
what is that [__] go you have a [__]
up lip do this fool ahead of Cliff Lee
but he wasn't acquire today plus are
ever ever again
I hear live in a fussy eater
I think you told me there was a drunk
guy one time singing I wanna move our
beetle broke bambina oh my gosh I
remember oh dude I remember going to
church right and I thought I was dope
because I they would let me drink wine I
was like 14 and good it's Kylie's degree
so I'm in and I would drink wine and I
saw in my head I would get all buzzed I
just draw that no now I heard they
changed it to grape juice well she got a
hurt from drinking out of the church cup
he got hurt herpes Cole blister that
would be holy here y'all drink out of
the same mother boy I wiped it man the
same metal cup yes yeah you guys do
communion every week in Catholic Church
yes see hold never had a cold sore yeah
if you're not Catholic you just do it
every once in a while and like big it's
like a big event
I'm telling you then you did your own
little cup you know the Catholic Church
people it's alcoholic depends what
priest it is is how strong the liquor is
yeah well the great boil would mix it
with walk with makes red wine and water
so it was my father wasn't in Fernando
the wandering I fired for blazing and
random honest brother Fernando grows up
and oh man I will have a molars a heart
a motorcycle bro and then like he'll go
cruise and then I will visit people and
then they come they got that for smoking
it's you know from the only priest I
renew that would like a beaten egg roll
the priest from life and times a tear me
yeah you seen heaven help us right with
Kevin Dillon
a bunch of other people and John Hurt is
in that and he's not John Hurt John
William Hurd the one who ever done her
the one who's in the dad in a [__]
home alone he's a priest but he smokes
and he lets the kids like get away with
whatever he Gamble's and all that stuff
and was he like that yeah like the bad
kid do you wanna fight you wanna box
alright box they gonna teach them how to
box but they didn't like the rear of
their boxers now he was God he was gone
he just disappeared out of our lives but
his his wine was strong for real bro
you'd be like didn't you get winery yeah
but it was good today so what can we
will find you while on social media oh
my gosh you can find me on Instagram
snapchat
Roxie are aq are yeah I saw my name are
aq capital C art Roxie it's a
combination of my first and my last name
you bets on that of course it's a
trademark duh we passed it was so full
right yeah we trade mark what's up full
Oh yours that's right a trait we got a
trademark you're a man seriously really
you know I'm the only dude I'm the only
person on in the world that knows her
name the way I do
nobody ever nobody spells I want the
girl from bt 106 no she spells her name
Chicago right yeah she Otto Xie aren't
oh I think ours is our toll CS I or
someone ever killed yeah my first
American they even have Ghoulia's about
rocket [__] dude I wasn't named Leo
Darla who Leo Dunn had a song called
Raquel toward being a guy yeah you know
I've been
okay z4 CCS lol what's that song but
what does a song about the guys thinking
meeting your [__] no me dijo que yo
good ass before if I'm if I'm a
transgender I've been telling you
believe that because of my raspy voice
[Laughter]
yeah
my voice is not that raspy no it's but I
think it's like sexy raspy you know it's
like if I whisper into your ear
something's going up not going down it's
going up yeah I'm a virgin
yeah bro it's a about a transgender name
bracket yeah it's a dope-ass on that let
me hear it
can we hear it name Raquel and if you
don't know now you know the white
version is called Caitlyn Jenner that's
not it
la primera yeah they young me you're
looking if how do you know
[Applause]
[Music]
Roxy
my god watching on YouTube after Roxy
pepper [__] rocks on Instagram snapchat
Roxy yeah so my snapchat is super poppin
y'all like I love snapchat as much as
people want to say whatever they want to
save a snapchat I got thirty three
million views on snapchat like I'm the
fab chat Queen what do you do like I
wouldn't put on stop you don't put on no
you know what I do is I I go off on my
rants you know like you know the way
cardi B goes off on Instagram I'm like
that on my social media as far as like I
just speak my mind and I story tell
right in my way get the world views but
that's true it's a little bit more
risque pictures I do
I'll admit that a little bit more risky
when you do those sort of videos what
was I gonna say I forgot something about
I don't know jack videos the rants like
when you do oh what I was gonna say is
so you talked openly on the pod can't
are on the show that you do every
morning with tattoo yeah you talk
whenever you go out in interviews or
public appearances and stuff like that
you talk I don't I feel like do you ever
feel like you run out you're gonna run
out of stuff to post or talk about when
you're doing that stuff no you know
because I feel like my snapchat is more
like my daily life and the things that I
cuss 'el when I'm out like cuz I have my
own brand right glasses hats and bathing
suits and so like I talked about like
the hustle being in you know going when
my manufacturer and and and I also
talked about like relationship stuff I
just this is the first time in my life
that I've been single so I talked about
like listen y'all if you're out there if
going through a heartbreak like you're
gonna get over it and I'll talk about
relationship stuff I'll talk about like
how I'm the product of divorced parents
after 23 years so I talk about different
things and I get people that ask me
questions so I'll start off my talk free
time base like eight like this guy hit
me up the other day he's like a Roxy
I have a situation with my girlfriend
she's telling me that I either have to I
have to be with her
I have to choose Racine her and my best
friend my best friend's been my friend
for the last 25 years but I love my girl
what should I do
as a woman do you think that my girl
should make me and should give me this
ultimatum and I was like no absolutely
not you're what the insecure woman like
I would never tell my man it's Eugene
your friends and me like if you're mad
prioritizes you he's gonna prioritize
you it's not even I don't have to tell
you it's a feeling it's a knowing you
know so guys women advice yeah like it's
just like so I'll get I'll answer advice
questions I'm just me girl that's it I'm
just me
I like I'd like to talk Shea I like to
be like look fellas like don't ever make
a girl feel like if you take her out
like she has to pay the bill that's some
[__] and then I'll go off on that
you know just different things a lot of
a lot of fools to think that though what
they owe them a little piece they pay
for the dinner yeah so I'll talk about
like look ladies have you ever gone out
with the dude and then you feel after
you got to give him a piece of ass
because he makes you feel that way and
then I'll get I'll talk about stuff like
that so yeah yep like never ending yeah
for reals I know some dudes you want to
get nasty either way late right away eat
those titties which would be a piece of
ass too much porn huh bro
G I know bro I watching a taxi driver
and I want you to like taking that out
yeah man that guy rubbed the nearest
character like here maybe watch it too
much live porn bro on his first date he
took it to a porn movie the Psychopaths
that happened now like that would be a
hit
bro these two have but now it before
like when I was a little kid these two
have two of them right there on where
subway is on 15 grand
no 16 grand really 13 grand yeah they
should be called the Pussycat theater
bro that was it sure wasn't Fred
Willard's found in there
yeah yeah it was like only a few years
what's up people this week I better
check up in Chicago
July 13 at the big theater two shows two
suns I wanted the casinos July 26 the
other Democrats you know killing Texas
who's gonna be in Killeen if you were a
Ford hood show up to kill in Texas or if
you missed the Austin show I'll just go
through a third twice as funny comedy
club Naples Florida
August 9th to the 11 after her comedy
club with Captain Brian and his whole
family will be there watching everybody
eat and laugh San Jose California
August 16th through the 18th at the San
Jose improv McAllen Texas Lubbock Texas
and Philadelphia all coming up people
I'm gonna be at the helium comedy club
in Philadelphia have a cup I forgot
myself smelly following on Instagram
comic-con Rizzo what are the next jokes
Joe at the Riverside thank you very much
for everybody came out last night to
view those jokes and next Viva Las Josie
will be in Spanish and that's gonna be
August 13th and that's the second
Tuesday of every month the Riverside at
life Arts Building right there in
downtown thank you everybody who showed
up to say yes say ves in Long Beach for
that stand-up comedy show it did it was
all in Spanish it was fun you did stand
at one time right oh my god I did
stand-up like like I want to say like
three times and I've read your couch
right well I did one more one time I did
it at the there's this one place it's
like a legendary place that man at the
Laugh Factory with the hi man Jamie
Masada
so I actually man this was all when I
was on the radio station and they're
like hey we're having Latino night there
and we need you to host like we need you
to basically be the host to like bring
out the comedian's and Jaime goes but I
want you to do like a five-minute say or
like it and I was like what I don't do
comedy like I only host and he was like
yeah but
but just you know it's cool it's easy
just be yourself and so I call couch my
boy DJ couch and I was like dude what do
I do
I got like a medium friend but I haven't
I'm like he's like basically just go
back and like think about cuz you know
I'm not a comedian for a living so he's
like just go back and like think about
different things that happen in your
life that could relate to the audience
and he try to break it down to the best
of his ability and I roll all my jokes
in my hand according to me they were
jokes but [__] cracking up
because I'm an improv person like that's
what in radio you prepare but you're
also you're never on the put on the spot
because you're improving you're reacting
to your audience to your calls to your
co-host so I had a blast and then Momo
Rodriguez invited me to open but to do a
little five minute sit at the Brea
improv twice nice and I was like yeah I
was like what that I don't even know
what I'm doing on the stage I just got
invited to come see what's up what's up
for more cool more do you have the show
this week right I think it's tonight or
tomorrow let me go see I think there's
free tickets right now he's giving
someone with the bread improv I guess I
got a piece Oh running the show already
you're ending the show wrapping up right
shut up - Roxy thank you very much
awesome come back anytime man tomorrow
tomorrow go check on Momo Rodriguez
brain Brown Charlie I'm gonna tell Joel
grunting zvu wants to come on the show
yeah I love it
all right guys bye yeah